président monsieur le Président c'est un
honneur et un privilège de représenter
aujourd'hui le Comité européen des
régions en tant que membre de la
délégation de l'Union européenne à la
cop27 est représentant de la
circonscription des gouvernements locaux
et autorités municipales étant moi-même
mère d'Autun en France en effet des
mères des présidents de région des élus
locaux de toute l'Europe et du monde
entier sont venus ces deux dernières
semaines à Charmelle cher pour partager
leur ambition climatique bien souvent
supérieure à celle de leurs états mais
aussi pour démontrer qu'ils sont la
source et le moteur de l'action
climatique sur le terrain le
réchauffement climatique est un des
filles global qui nécessite des actions
locales sans les acteurs publics locaux
et sans une collaboration multiniveaux
structurée et effective nous
n'arriverons ni à atteindre les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris ni
atténuer l'impact du changement
climatique dans nos sociétés les
gouvernements locaux et régionaux
remercient par conséquent la présidence
égyptienne d'avoir organisé avec le
soutien de habitat la toute première
réunion ministérielle sur l'urbanisation
et le changement climatique lors d'une
Coop nous invitons donc les prochaines
résidences de la COP a convoquer une
réunion ministérielle sur l'urbanisation
et le changement climatique comme c'est
l'organisait à la cop27 en tant que
point permanent à l'ordre du jour et en
particulier nous saluons le lancement du
programme résiliente
urbaine durable pour la prochaine
génération search la circonscription des
gouvernements locaux et des autorités
municipales invitant en outre le
secrétariat et les futurs présidents a
proposé d'inclure formellement le rôle
des collectivités territoriales dans
l'élaboration des contributions
déterminées nationalement et la
rédaction des plans nationaux
d'adaptation si nous nous félicitons
enfin que le financement des pertes et
préjudices et étaient abordées nous
pensons que se posera à terme
inévitablement la question du
financement direct des collectivités
territoriales que nous défendons depuis
des années
la circonscription des gouvernements
locaux et des autorités municipales
notre néanmoins avec inquiétude que la
question de l'adaptation portée à
l'échelle locale n'attire pas
l'attention qu'elle mérite la diplomatie
communale et régionale est
insuffisamment reconnue et utilisé or la
coopération décentralisée est un levier
puissant d'accélération de l'action
climatique locale
lgmée et un FCC unissons nos forces pour
tenir les promesses de la prochaine
phase de l'accord de Paris je vous
remercie